- Guten Tag, Frau González!
- Guten Tag.
- Äh, könnte ich bitte einen Kaffee haben?
- Gerne.
- Wie geht es Ihnen?
- Danke, gut.
Aber vielleicht bald nicht mehr,
wenn weiterhin jeder seine
Abgase in die Luft bläst.
- Hm?
- Nicht Sie …
- Schon wieder Herr Murz?
- Wenn er minutenlang seinen Motor
nicht abstellt,
dann ist das nicht nur Lärmbelästigung.
Es ist auch schlecht für die Umwelt!
- Vielleicht wollte er den Wagen aufheizen.
- Wenn die Belastung weiter zunimmt
und die
Klimaprognosen der Forscher und
Experten eintreten,
dann wird sich hier bald
sowieso alles erwärmen.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch!
- Also ich wäre nicht böse über
eine Klimaänderung.
Die Kälte heute ist wirklich furchtbar.
- Die globale Erwärmung ist eine Tatsache.
Es wird immer wärmer.
Und es werden immer mehr Treibhausgase
in die Atmosphäre geblasen.
Von Menschen wie Herrn Murz!
- Ach, nun kommen Sie schon.
- Was zahlt der Ihnen eigentlich, damit
Sie ihm das alles durchgehen lassen, hä?
- Mehr als Sie …